mr don lemon is a cable news host on our
competitor over at cnn and most of the
time he talks about
cable news host type things what the
royals are up to
how a commercial airliner might have
flown into a black hole you know the
news
but don lemon is most importantly more
than that
don lemon is a civil rights leader and
just the other day he spoke to the
washington post about his feelings on
civil rights and he declared you may not
be surprised by this that america is a
racist country
quote we're living in two different
realities
as black and white people said father
lamont
it was interesting we read that and we
thought well here's a guy who makes
millions of dollars a year for presiding
over a show that is
failing that seems like a pretty good
deal but
like so many don lemon is also a victim
a successful victim and so we asked on
the victim scale on the scale of say
meghan markle to michelle obama
just how oppressed is don lamont what is
the different
reality he is forced to live in as a
black man in america
well we did a little digging and here
are the details
don lamont lives in a 4.3 million
home in sag harbor harbor new york no he
does not live in section 8 housing
he lives in one of the whitest towns in
america in fact 80 percent
sag harbor is just 3 percent
african-american
now in the interview mr lamont said
america needs to see more people
like him he regularly lectures america
about
diversity what he didn't tell the
washington post is that in his free time
he runs away from diversity his reality
is that he doesn't like diversity
at all none of them do but here's the
most troubling discovery
about mr lamont now you have heard from
the white house from the president
himself that white supremacy
is a lurking threat you might not always
see it but it's always there like
russian spies white supremacists
come in the dark of night in the most
surprising form they're shape-shifters
now we're not calling anybody a white
supremacist here
but you have to ask yourself i'm going
to put this on the screen now
what is this this symbol of hate
symbol of hate posing as a cookie jar
doing in don lemon's kitchen
do you see that that right there ladies
and gentlemen
is a white supremacist q anon cookie jar
now we're not calling for the department
of justice to look more deeply into this
because that's not our place
we're a cable news show not a law
enforcement agency
but let's just put it this way if you
find yourself with a blackface cookie
jar in your own kitchen
it's time to reflect that means you
don lemon hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else